no Steve Carell didn't leave the office
for a starring role in Threat Level
Midnight so why did he choose to say
goodbye to Michael Scott and Dunder
Mifflin in April 2010 Steve Carell made
the first public mention that his days
at Dunder Mifflin were possibly numbered
he told the BBC that because his
contract for the office only ran through
season 7 The then forthcoming season
would likely be his last on the series
according to interviews published in
Andy Green's book The Office the untold
story of the greatest sitcom of the
2000s the lack of internal response to
Carell's comment about season 7
potentially being his last actually made
the actor feel like it was time to leave
Brian Whittle who worked as a boom
operator and sound mixer on the office
explained the sequence of events in the
book he described how Carell went into
the interview and said what he said off
the cuff for the actor he was simply
thinking out loud and said what was on
his mind at the time however when his
comments made the news and no one from
the show contacted him about what was
said Carell actually thought they didn't
care and it might be time to hit the
bricks I'm getting out of town hair
stylist Kim fery backed up whittle's
story she noted that Carell wanted to
stay on and had told the NBC brass that
he planned on signing a new contract
that would be good for a few more years
according to Ferry however Network
Executives simply didn't reach out to
him about negotiating a new deal she
stated and the deadline came for when
they were supposed to give him an offer
and it passed and they didn't make him
an offer so his agent was like well I
guess they don't want to renew you for
some reason which was insane to me and
to him I think she noted that Carell
didn't want to leave the office behind
but he simply had no other choice in
this matter she explained how a lot of
people believe he left the show because
he wanted to and on his own terms when
that wasn't the truth fer said she was
there and saw how badly he wanted to
stay but it was out of his hands more
importantly she believes his departure
hurt the show because he was at the
center of it casting director Allison
Jones called the whole situation silly
because Carell truly wanted to stay on
the show she reaffirmed what fery had
said explaining how the actor wanted to
do another season but NBC didn't make
the deal in Desperate situations yield
the quickest results
the office producer Randy cordre offered
another element that contributed to
Carell's departure the arrival of Bob
greenblat who became the chairman of NBC
entertainment in 2011 allegedly
greenblat wasn't the biggest fan of the
office and appeared to take the popular
show for granted cordre noted his beli
that Carell likely would have stayed on
the show if there was more respect
coming from NBC he said if you're not
respected and don't even get offered a
contract or a discussion of a future
contract then you move on for what it's
worth greenblat maintained in the office
The Untold story of the greatest sitcom
of the 2000s that it was out of his
hands to prevent Carell from leaving the
series since he believed it was already
happening before his promotion don't
listen to your critics listen to your
fans putting aside the circumstances
detailed in Andy Green's oral history
Steve Carell has addressed his departure
and said that it was actually the right
time for him his character storyline Arc
wrapped up in a satisfying way speaking
to former co-stars Jenna Fischer and
Angela Kinsey on their popular recap
podcast office ladies in March 2023
three Carell mentioned Michael's final
full episode as his favorite one he said
my last one talk about heart it was a
really difficult episode to do but I
also loved it at the same time because
it was sort of that end game for Michael
it was the culmination the sort of
showing the growth that he didn't need
the big send off he didn't need the big
party he could say goodbye to all of his
friends on his own terms without any of
the Fanfare when fiser and Kinsey recall
that it was a difficult final few weeks
on set with Carell largely because
everybody loved him so much the
seemingly modest star said he felt it
was time for him to go he said it was
difficult because we were such good
friends and it had been so much fun and
so rewarding in a lot of ways always but
at the same time there was this for me
there was a joy to it when you're crying
with joy because it wasn't even sadness
like because I was ready I was ready to
go and so I wasn't sad about leaving
I've always wanted to be in the witness
protection program not only did Steve
Carell tell jfisher and Angela Kinsey
that his timing was right for Michael's
overall Journey he specifically
mentioned that his exit would allow
other characters to take Center Stage he
said it was time for other characters to
kind of step to the Forefront and other
storylines to be pursued the timing was
right I think for everybody but
simultaneously there was just a sense of
joy for me that we had experienced all
of this and I was getting a chance to
kind of take a lap with everybody Carell
added it was an emotional time but he
was grateful for the opportunity to say
goodbye to Michael while working with
his friends now whether or not that
actually paid off is a big question for
fans of the office considering how
poorly new characters like Nelly were
received after Michael's exit however
it's clear Carell got the closure he
wanted from his final days on set
congratulations
Universe you win ultimately Steve
Carell's career definitely didn't suffer
after he left the office he has been on
an upward trajectory ever since the same
year he left the popular show he
appeared in Crazy Stupid Love following
that with Indie movies like Seeking a
Friend for the End of the World and the
way way back as well as continuing his
franchise streak in the Despicable meee
movies the year 2014 brought Carell's
first brush with major Awards shows
thanks to his showy yet terrifying
Central performance in Fox catcher and
he picked up more nominations the
following year working with his Anchor
Man director Adam McKay on The Big Short
after a string of renowned films Carell
appeared alongside a star studded cast
in Wes Anderson's asteroid City in 2023
Carell made his Grand return to
television in 2019 turning to drama with
Apple TV's Flagship series The Morning
Show where he plays disgraced news
anchor Mitch Kessler with his character
killed off in season 2 Carell returned
to Comedy in the Netflix series space
force most notably Carell also starred
in The Limited series the patient where
he portrays a therapist kidnapped by his
violent unstable
patient